okay so we did part one of this wacky
georgia weekend wherein we looked at
donald trump's speech at a rally in
commerce georgia but i told you there
would be three parts we'll eventually
get to the rally attendees but first i
want to do something intermediate which
is to look at some of the people on the
stage some of the other people who
participated in the rally because at uh
very often at these rallies we say
you've got the craziness of trump and
you've got the craziness of the rally
goers but here we actually have really
in its full glory
the level of delusion and depravity of
the people that still are willing and
interested in associating themselves
with donald trump including candidates
and current elected officials and so
let's go through some of those first and
foremost radical georgia congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene was at the rally
she spoke at the rally and before
speaking she was interviewed and uh here
she puts together some
outrageous uh idea
that they if they take this the house
will investigate hunter biden's laptop
now hunter biden has nothing to do with
the administration i don't know why
anyone's still talking about his laptop
but take a listen to this and they were
doing all these shady business deals in
ukraine and other countries
what they were doing is investing in bio
labs
interested in bio weapons and my team is
already looking into it and i have to
tell you we had our republican retreat
for the past couple of days and there's
going to be a new republican party
coming back in washington and we're
playing oversight committees on every
single committee there will be oversight
investigations and you better bet hunter
by the laptop will be top of the list
so there's about four funny things there
number one
there's going to be a new republican
party if that's true i don't think she's
going to be part of it and what i mean
by that is there's increasingly pressure
within the republican party to get the
hell away from people like marjorie
taylor green so if there's a new
republican party she'll be gone number
two she talks about all of the things
committees are going to do she's been
kicked off every committee that's also a
funny thing now of course if republicans
win in the fall they may put marjorie
taylor green back on committees that's
fair but the idea that hunter biden's
laptop is going to be a top priority i
don't think she's kidding i think she's
telling the truth and that's what makes
it so scary
then she jumped into the typical
anti-semitic tropes see if you can spot
them here some of the topics you're
going to talk about
well what i'll be talking about is some
of what i've talked about right now but
i'll also be talking about how there's a
globalist agenda and that agenda is
being brought forth by the world
economic forum
klaus schwab and all of their cronies
these are the same people that you know
what they want right now is they want
war and more war because they love
crisis and they love to use it to their
political advantage now i know the
topics are going to many of our
untrained ears you might not recognize
anything she said as anti-semitic and i
concede
she may not mean these things in an
openly anti-semitic way but this is the
same old trope of
globalist
control the one guy she mentions is
jewish
for the personal gain of the people
doing the controlling often they say
klaus schwab and george soros
globalist is another buzz word sometimes
these people don't even realize
that these all of these ideas have a
basis in anti-semitism but it's marjorie
taylor green and she doesn't realize the
origins of half the things that she says
then matt gates spoke matt gates also
spoke at the rally and he says he wants
trump to be speaker of the house if
republicans win in november give us the
ability to fire nancy pelosi take back
the majority
impeach joe biden and i'm going to
nominate donald trump for speaker of the
united states house of representatives
thank you very much thank you everybody
[Music]
well that was interesting
yeah now again i don't think it's going
to work out for them but there is really
a movement within the republican party
to make trump speaker of the house if
they win in november remember that you
don't have to be a member of the house
to be speaker of the house anybody can
be made speaker of the house it's just
traditionally it's been a member of the
house and then we got to
a really ugly phase in the event which
is when herschel walker spoke
herschel walker who recently said
if monkeys still exist how could
evolution be real
here he is
listen to this americans we're not black
we're not white we're american we're all
mutts i hate to tell you that
we should have learned a long time ago
that 23 of me has screwed us all up
that's really the enemy guys 23 and me
and then herschel walker
apparently wanting to talk about crt
critical race theory instead talking
about ctr for this country
people want to ask me all the time while
i'm running i'm sick and tired yeah i
mean i have no idea why he's running
it's a good question i'm sick and tired
i didn't want to
teach ctr in
school
critical race theory can you tell me
what that mean
we can uh and again i i this is a guy
who's taken a lot of hits to the head he
may have a brain injury
that's not a joke i mean he played
football for a while heisman trophy
winner college football pro football um
he does seem to often be extraordinarily
confused during these speeches and ctr
that's click-through rate in advent in
the world of advertising ctr
is a very important metric and uh maybe
he wants it taught in school and then
here is marjorie taylor green
barely able to see over the lectern
going on a very homophobic rant about
pete budage and i'll explain that to you
in a moment and you know what
pete butterjudge can take his electric
vehicles and his bicycles and he and his
husband can stay out of our girls
bathrooms
that is man that is so depressing
that's standard right-wing homophobic
nuttery and it's the idea that gay men
are pedophiles
why would pete buddha judge be
interested in hanging out in a girl's
bathroom it doesn't make any sense and
of course the disdain for bicycles you
don't like bicycles you don't like
electric vehicles like what is there not
to like about an electric vehicle so
this is part two of our exploration of
the rally in georgia we looked at the
trump nuttery and now the acolyte
nuttery next and lastly
no more this is the last part we will
look at the attendees